Ngày 1 môi thân lắm, đến gần linh lên tiếng chỉ trích Amenia sau khi tổng thủ quay đà bố lùi đi mẹ dưới lần ski tới thăm trứng tương nơi này và có cơ phát biểu bị mắt sửa bà coi là bài ngà tại tụi đô dí rời bán.
Zip bên lời cho thấy quan hệ dưới 2,000 tưởng thuộc liên bà sau viết tiếp tục giả lất.
Cú thể người phân ông địa gần lý đi mi truy pェ sq. cho biết ngà không thể xem việc Amenia tạo dịt đàn cho các tuyên bố nhằm trong lạm mắt sq. vào là điều bình thường.
Ông nhìn mạnh điều quan trọng nhất bình á lắm Amenia không lợi trọng lập trường bà ngà.
Đúng thôi cho biết mắt sq. vào đăng trở giải thích chính thức từ kia dưới văn.
Châu đò trong truyền thăm Amenia ngày 1.5, OBSNSK KIA y tư bố ngà có thể sẽ cần trở bị chất viên cạnh của bây có thể sơ điện trên bộng trời quan trường đò.
Trong dịt blade sức viên ngà trên thăm của chỉ là năm sau phát biểu này ngà đã chụt lại sự Amenia để phản đối.
Điều mắt sq. vào gọi là những lời đe dọa như mong á.
Người phần ngôn đi mình truyết xấu của định văn lình túc mấy tỏ lòng át Amenia đang sức lại gần lưới mình cho ông sau khi nước này tổ chức hội gị tóc lòng chính trị cho ông.
Với sự thăm dự của hơn gồm mới lạnh đạo cho ông bao gồm cóng dây lệ sĩ.
Từng là đường mưng gần gũi khi cũng phục liên xấu trụ đầy sẽ bản này là tóc lòng nó có ra được lập sê iet.
Có thể ngà Amenia xuất hiện giả nất kể được khi a sức bài ra anh dành lạc khu tực nát của nát, các là bác trình chất với Amenia.
Năm hành gị phục chồng hề bà.
Bất chấp sự hiện giả nất của lực lượng dây lửa hả bình nát.